well this season is testing the golden
knights ability to adapt after
thursday's game at san jose was
postponed
vegas moved on to anaheim john treach
has more from the west division leaders
hey john
hey there kirsten the golden knights
will play a road game in anaheim
tomorrow but the disneyland anticipation
will come next week
beginning monday there will be authentic
human noise in the fortress
and it will be music to the hockey
player ears
just like the magic kingdom fans will be
running through the turnstiles on march
1st and the players will be eager
and perhaps nervous to perform in front
of them despite another postponed game
at
san jose on thursday well vegas remains
the first place team
in the west 2600 people get to see them
live it won't be the full house of old
but it will feel like home sweet home
i can't wait um you know this is
you know fans are one of the main
reasons why this is the place that i
wanted to come to um you know we
uh sell out our rink united night
out uh you know they watch us when we're
on the road
and they're supportive of us and through
ups and downs
uh and we're just excited to have them
back um
you know obviously it's a limited
capacity and but it's gonna feel
uh it's gonna feel so nice to to have
them back
in the meantime mark still may go to
sport clips in between we'll see
as for tomorrow night's game the first
place golden knights will play against
the last place
ducks the puck will drop at 7 p.m